hallo und willkommen zu zdf heute live
rund zwei monate sind vergangen seit der
flut im juli eine der schwersten
unwetter-katastrophen in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik auch heute sind noch
ganze ortschaften in rheinland pfalz in
nordrhein westfalen und auch in bayern
verwüstet und ganz klar die menschen
sind auf hilfe angewiesen gucken wir uns
das mal an von denen versicherungen
braucht es geld vom staat aber auch
natürlich durch private spenden und das
glück ist die spendenbereitschaft die
ist immens hoch mehrere hundert
millionen euro sind bereits
zusammengekommen
wenn man alle spenden zusammen rechnet
die frage ist bei vielen betroffenen
allerdings wie und wo komme ich an die
spenden ran wie läuft die verteilung der
spenden genau und die zeit drängt für so
manchen denn die kalten monate stehen ja
bevor und mit den baumaßnahmen müsste an
vielen stellen dringend begonnen werden
eines der großen spendenbündnissen
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
allein bereits mehr als 87 millionen
euro gesammelt darin vertreten ist unter
anderem auch die diakonie und mit der
leiterin der öffentlichkeitsarbeit des
diakonischen werks
rheinland-westfalen-lippe
sprechen wir jetzt einen schönen guten
abend frau hahn hallo
guten abend herr herrmann also frau
haben gehört da gibt es im moment
relativ viel geld zu verteilen wie weit
sind sie damit wo stehen sie da gerade
was passiert passiert sind wenn ganz
unterschiedliche sachen also es gab ich
sage mal vier verschiedene bausteine was
bisher mit den spendengeldern gemacht
wurde ein baustein war es beispielsweise
die soforthilfe also man sich vorstellt
dass es viele gibt die von einem moment
auf den nächsten vor dem nichts standen
wo die ganze wohnung weggeschwemmt ist
und da ging es um ja wir sind es
manchmal zaun geld weil man sich so
vorstellen muss wie über den gartenzaun
reicht also gelder bis zu 1500 euro für
das nötigste was in den ersten tagen
gebraucht wurde also kleidung
nahrungsmittel medikamente was auch
immer gebraucht wurde da hat die
diakonie rheinland westfalen lippe
gemeinsam mit der diakonie
katastrophenhilfe bisher etwa 3,2
millionen euro an spenden ausgegeben
etwa 1200 familien wurden unterstützt
aber auch soziale einrichtungen also in
jugendzentren
beratungsstellen seniorenheime weil all
das natürlich auch vor ort stütze und
halt gibt und auch die konten sofort
hilfe beantragen also das war ein
baustein beispielsweise aber es gibt
manchmal auch ganz ganz technische dinge
die die nötig waren und die umgesetzt
wurden direkt am anfang also werden uns
dass der reihe nach anschlagsopfern
genau also das ist natürlich eine ganze
reihe von maßnahmen die da eben auch
finanziert und unterstützt werden auch
von ihnen das gucken wir uns an wir
werden sie heute abend aber auch mit
einigen kritischen aussagen oder auch
fragen von betroffenen konfrontieren das
bleibt nicht aus aber uns geht es um
konstruktive lösungen es geht auch darum
vielleicht einverständnis herzustellen
für die probleme die auch damit
verbunden sind so einen großen betrag
dann auch zu managen das kommt ja auch
nicht alle tage vor und das ist für sie
mit sicherheit auch nicht immer ganz
einfach wir fangen wir an mit dieser
dame hier aus erftstadt bliesheim in
nordrhein westfalen mein name ist ein
melbach ich war mit meinem mann den us
top design
in einem alten fachwerkhof und dieser
wurde
von dem hochwasser stark beschädigt dass
im erdgeschoss und objekt männer sind
vollgelaufen und jetzt muss kernsaniert
werden uns brauchen einige kosten auf
uns zu wo wir natürlich auch auf
spendengelder angewiesen wären wir sind
jetzt acht wochen und nach der
katastrophe und wir haben noch keinerlei
info bekommen an denen man sich wenden
muss unsere dorfgemeinschaft die
unterstützung sind ja dann letztendlich
anträge vorbeigebracht aber von nix
organisation selber haben wir bis heute
noch keine offiziellen infos erhalten
also frau haben sie sind natürlich nicht
überall selbst zuständig das ist klar
aber wir nehmen das jetzt einfach mal
weil wir sie jetzt heute im gespräch
haben so ein bisschen pars pro toto also
die frage nach der fehlenden präsenz vor
ort man weiß nicht genau an wen man sich
wenden soll was können sie dazu sagen
also alle diakonie ist es so dass die
deponien vor ort zuständig sind und an
die man sich wenden kann manchmal war es
so dass natürlich auch die diakonin vor
ort zerstört waren da sind aber sehr
konstruktiv auch die diakonien aus den
angrenzenden gebieten eingesprungen also
beim von der soforthilfe beispielsweise
haben zum beispiel
gelder beantragt und in dieses gebiet
gebracht
also ansprechpartner für die betroffenen
sind für uns immer die diakonie vor ort
in absprache mit dem landesverband in
düsseldorf und da haben sie das gefühl
dass die nati diejenigen die zuständig
sind
die sind präsent und wenn jetzt die
kritik aufkommt das ist vielleicht nicht
immer ganz klar ist dass vielleicht
etwas was wir uns anziehen müssen es
wird sich ändern was wir gerade aufbauen
sind mobile teams die in verschiedenen
regionen sind die besonders betroffen
sind die auch umgehen und unterstützen
bei anträgen
beim ausfüllen von was sie weiß gar
nicht wo beantragen welche staatlichen
leistungen was mache ich mit der
versicherungen machen die also vor sind
und im zweifel noch präsenter sind aber
jeder vor ort kann gelder beantragen und
es wurde auch schon viele beantragt also
niemand muss sorge haben dass eben nicht
geholfen wird in diese richtung geht
auch die frage von lone wolf ich habe
die formulare gesehen die sind mega
kompliziert die meisten opfer der
flutkatastrophe sind zwischen 45 und 80
jahre alt selbst deren kinder und enkel
mit büro hintergrund haben probleme
dadurch zu steigen es ist einfach eine
frechheit was alles verlangt wird um
ausgezahlt zu werden und dann auch noch
von schnell und unkompliziert zu
sprechen na ja das mag bestimmt auch in
teilen so sein wie gesagt sie sind jetzt
ja auch nicht für alles verantwortlich
aber wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe geht es ihnen auch darum hilfe zu
leisten beim ausfüllen zb dieser
formulare
also diese formulare sind tatsächlich
noch unbürokratisch da gibt es auch
keine bedürftigkeitsprüfungen sondern
man muss nur den schaden belegen und
jetzt im falle der jetzt haben wir noch
den soforthilfen die die haushaltshilfen
heißen die wo man bis zu 5000 euro
beantragen kann für vermögen für hausrat
für eine neue küche für was auch immer
gerade ein haus rat benötigt wird und
den muss man ausfüllen muss nur den
schaden
belegen und kann es schon einreichen
dass es immer noch ziemlich
unbürokratisch und ohne viel ohne eine
bedürftigkeitsprüfung aber diese mobilen
teams werden auch dabei unterstützen
also jemand der sich schwer tut mit
anträgen wir haben das mit mehreren
betroffenen die anträge eingereicht
haben durchgespielt ob diese formulare
verstanden werden ob das jeder
nachvollziehen kann und das war wurde
und so zurückgespiegelt dass es
verständlich ist jetzt kann ich nicht
für die anderen organisationen sprechen
aber die rückmeldung war das ist
verständlich für diejenige sich schwer
tun auch vielleicht mit der eigenen
finanziellen situation was was kann ich
eigentlich machen auch dort werden
mobile teams helfen hilfen zu bekommen
also es geht nicht nur um das auszahlen
von geldern das natürlich besonders
wichtig und da steht auch im vordergrund
aber es geht auch darum hilfe also hilfe
zu geben die hilfen zu bekommen und das
wird verstärkt ausgebaut wird in kürze
vor ort zu sehen weil sie die anderen
organisationen auch gerade angesprochen
haben sind insgesamt vier organisationen
nicht richtig weiß die da
zusammengefasst sind in diesem
aktionsbündnis und da würde ich fragen
wollen ist das denn auch vielleicht ein
problem also die koordination
untereinander oder haben sie das gefühl
die zusammenarbeit läuft gut
dem finde es gut es gibt ganz enge
austausch runden
regelmäßig im moment treffen wir uns
vier mal die woche und da gibt es auch
schon zu dem was denn
läuft außerdem gibt es bei diesen
haushalt beihilfen wie sie heißen eine
zentrale datenbank die alle
hilfsorganisationen zu greifen so dass
jeder sehen kann was woanders beantragt
wurde diese datenbank wurde schon
2013 bei der flut benutzt und hat sich
bewährt so dass eben auch klar ist dass
da kein missbrauch betrieben werden kann
denn wir sind ja schon schuldig den
spendern dass wir sagen können wo die
gelder hingehen und die sollen eben
unbürokratisch vor allem bei denen
landen die sie besonders nötig haben
genau die leute auch brauchen das ist
klar darüber sprechen wir kann sich auch
noch über ihren reservaten genau über
die maßnahmen die sie ergreifen können
um da auch missbrauch vorzubeugen vielen
dank für den moment also die verteilung
der spenden das ist klar die ist nicht
ganz einfach wo da weitere
schwierigkeiten auch noch lauern dass
wir uns jetzt nochmal anschauen
noch nie haben menschen nach einer
naturkatastrophe in deutschland so viel
geld gespendet wie nach dem hochwasser
im juli allein beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe auf dessen
spendenkonten das zdf hinweist sind
87,1 millionen euro eingegangen
gleichmäßig aufgeteilt auf caritas
deutsches rotes kreuz und diakonie davon
sind bisher aber erst rund fünf
millionen euro ausgezahlt worden als
soforthilfen und haushaltshilfen bis
maximal 5000 euro weitere gelder sind in
andere maßnahmen geflossen wie mobile
arztpraxen oder notunterkünfte wie viel
das gekostet hat es bisher unklar in den
nächsten monaten soll es vor allem um
den wiederaufbau gehen hierhin schließen
die meisten spenden zuerst muss aber
geklärt werden ob eine versicherung
einspringt dann wie viel der staat an
hilfe bereitstellt zuletzt kommen die
spendengelder und es gibt noch weitere
hürden es gibt zurzeit gespräche von
hilfsorganisationen mit den jeweils
zuständigen finanzbehörden mit denen sie
sicherstellen möchten dass etwa bei der
unterstützung von
wiederaufbau von gebäuden nicht im
nachhinein dann das als nicht
gemeinnützige und damit für sie
schädliche ausgabe angesehen wird bis
die gelder verteilt sind werden viele
betroffene also noch geduld brauchen
in der tat relativ kompliziert vor allem
wenn man sich anguckt welche hürden dann
noch so lauern dass man also da
verschiedene auch wege einhalten muss
und mit der geduld frau hahn ist es
natürlich auch nicht so einfach jetzt
stehen die kalten monate vor der tür und
wenn dann das haus irgendwie ja mehr
oder weniger weg ist und man eigentlich
mit dem aufbau jetzt mal dringend
beginnen müsste dann haben natürlich
viele leute nicht so viel zeit können
sie die trotzdem beruhigen
also eine sache die wir jetzt sofort
umsetzen das ist in dieser woche
gestartet ist das thema heizungs geräte
klar ist dass die infrastruktur vor ort
massiv beschädigt ist und
das wasser alles möglich zerstört ist
und klar absehbar ist dass das viele
haushalte im herbst und winter ohne
heizung da stehen werden weil sie im
zweifel im keller verbaut war und mit
schlamm und wasser überspült wurde wir
haben die diakonie hat etwa 4000
heizungs geräte bestellt die ersten
wurde diese woche ausgeliefert immer
dezentral mit dem die augen vor ort
das sind keine geräte für die ewigkeit
aber klar ist dass es über die jetzige
die jahreszeit die sie ansprechen jetzt
herbst und winter müssen die menschen
mit mit geräten über die runden kommt
vorher war das thema bautrockner da
damit die häuser vor schimmel geschützt
werden und vor weiteren schäden
auch da wurde schon etwa eine millionen
ausgegeben und jetzt ist das thema
heizgeräte damit
man jetzt erstmal über die nächste zeit
über die runden kommen also um das
vielleicht gerade noch mal aufzudröseln
sie hatten es für den auch schon
angesprochen also erst gab es die
soforthilfen das war das was sie als
sozusagen zaun geld auf bezeichnet haben
bis maximal 1500 euro die
haushaltshilfen das läuft im moment bis
maximal 5000 euro und dann kommen ja die
wiederaufbauhilfe gibt es da auch eine
obergrenze und ab wann kann man mit
denen dann wohl rechnen
es ist so dass spenden grundsätzlich
keine staatlichen leistungen und auch
keine versicherungsleistung ersetzen
dürfen das ist im spenden rechts
festgesetzt das heißt im grunde muss man
jetzt warten
was der staat übernehmen kann was die
versicherung übernehmen und die
staatlichen leistungen können in
nordrhein westfalen erst ab heute
beantragt werden in rheinland-pfalz was
ja noch betroffen ist stark wird es ab
oktober sein das heißt das muss da
vorgeschaltet sein die spendengelder
werden dann für die entstandenen lücken
also die staatlichen hilfen sollen etwa
80 prozent der schäden abdecken 20
prozent soll eigenanteil sein und wäre
das nicht leisten kann also ein beispiel
jemand hat ein haus gekauft gerade oder
fertig gebaut und der soll jetzt 20
prozent eigenanteil am schaden dass das
geld hat er natürlich nicht das geld ist
weg jetzt gerade und an diesen stellen
springen die hilfsorganisationen ein und
dafür würden die spendengelder genutzt
das heißt die schritte sind staatliche
mittel
versicherungen und dann kommen die
spende und wie gesagt in nordrhein
westfalen ist es ab heute möglich dass
zu beantragen sie sprechen also von den
staatlichen hilfen da ist ein paket in
höhe von insgesamt 30 milliarden euro
geschnürt worden in den letzten wochen
von der politik in den letzten tagen
eine frage von thomas garms über
facebook wie viel geld von den spenden
geht dann in die bürokratische
verarbeitung der organisation oder
werden die spenden komplett an die opfer
weitergeleitet
also bei der diakonie in
westfalen lippe ist es bisher so dass
wir aktuell das noch mit den normalen
bordmitteln machen da wird es mobile
teams vor ort geben das was wir eben
sagt haben größtenteils sind die auch
mitarbeiter die bisher schon vor ort
waren aber das werden auch kollegen
eingestellt werden aber das ziel ist es
kein es soll keinen wasserkopf
verwaltung geben sondern
deshalb immer die zusammenarbeit mit den
diakonen vor ort sowohl bei den bau
trocknen oder heizgeräte oder bei der
beratung damit das nicht passiert also
ist es wird nicht massiv aufgebaut
sondern soll möglichst mit den mit den
diakonen in unserem fall mit den
informationen vor ort umgesetzt werden
also es hat niemand vorher etwas das
auch zu plänen sondern es sollte
möglichst immer dezentral vor ort mit
schlanken strukturen so zu sagen
sprechen wir noch mal kurz über das
stichwort
bedürftigkeitsprüfung sie hatten es
vorhin schon erwähnt am anfang gab es
die noch nicht aber jetzt wenn die
größeren summen natürlich dann
ausgezahlt werden sollen dann ist das ja
auch immer eine gerechtigkeitsfrage und
da muss man natürlich genauer hingucken
haben sie da sorge vor betrügern bzw was
können sie gegen betrug tun
also zum jetzigen stadium sind werden
noch in den bei diesen haushalt bei
helfen ohne diese 5000 euro ohne
bedürftigkeitsprüfung das andere wird
noch kommt und da sind wir es natürlich
den spender verpflichtet das zu
überprüfen also da wird es darum gehen
wer hat noch ein konto was gut gefüllt
ist und kann das noch bezahlen diesen
eigenanteil und wer kann diesen
geforderten eigenanteil nicht
nicht leisten und erst bei denjenigen
werden die wirklich aufbringen in dem
fall werden informationen mit spenden
einspringen aber dass sie dort überprüft
werden also wenn sie jetzt
sagen würde wir geben jedem einfach nur
1000 euro dann würden sie mich auch
fragen wieso geben sie jedem 100000 euro
das macht doch überprüft werden und da
muss man eben die finanzielle situation
offenlegen
haben sie da auch mal von sehr aber noch
nicht ja verstehen man könnte sich schon
vorstellen dass da die eine oder andere
neiddebatte auch entsteht warum kriegt
man nach tradition so viel und ich
vielleicht weniger oder ich habe die
ganze zeit in der versicherung
eingezahlt der nachbar nicht aber der
krieg jetzt über die spenden ist doch
ungerecht haben sie sorge für sowas
kann natürlich immer passieren kann
aber wir können nicht mehr machen als
überprüfen und nach den kriterien die
die gelten zu sagen wir wir überprüfen
die finanzielle situation
das hätten sie in jedem fall was jemand
sagt ich habe jetzt immer aber immer
sparsam neiddebatte werden sie nicht
vermeiden können wir können das nur
überprüfen wir können überprüfen und
sagen wir schauen wer diese 20 prozent
eigenleistung nicht übernehmen kann ja
vor einem anderen problem warnt dieser
mann hier immerhin ein bürgermeister
mein name ist stärker an der angell
prima ich bin ortsbürgermeister in
erftstadt friesheim
in der stadt selbst haben wir eine
vielzahl von personen die von der flut
direkt betroffen sind
erstmal sind wir natürlich froh und
dankbar dass es so eine große
hilfsbereitschaft in der breite der
gesellschaft gibt aber es gibt auch
viele spenden töpfe und viele sind noch
beschäftigt damit die folgen der flut zu
bewältigen und haben nicht die muße sich
die richtlinien und kriterien der
einzelnen spenden töpfer anzug
daraus folgt dass so ein bisschen das
wind und sie gilt das heißt wer zuerst
sich informiert kriegt vielleicht auch
als erster hilfe
ja frau ist das so wer zuerst kommt
mahlt zuerst frau hahn also das wäre ja
im prinzip nicht so schlimm wenn am ende
genug für alle da wäre aber hat er damit
einen punkt
ich denke dich also erst der flut 2013
ist hat man die erfahrung auch dass 80
prozent der spendengelder in dem schritt
2 und 3 ausgegeben werden also nicht in
der phase 1 so wie jetzt gerade noch
sind in dieser akutphase
das sind es nur 20 prozent das meiste
geld wird noch kommen ich will nicht
sagen dass ein marathon aber es immerhin
langstreckenlauf das geld ist da und es
wird auch kein problem sein wenn jemand
eben nicht so in der situation ist dass
ich jetzt schon zu kümmern oder
auch nicht den überblick hat vielleicht
wenn der in anderthalb jahren antrag
stellt wird das dasein das hat auch die
erfahrung gezeigt es ist da und die
hoffnung besteht dass mit diesen mobilen
teams eben genau die menschen die sich
vielleicht sonst auch an diakonie oder
caritas gewandt haben weil sie
vielleicht hilfe im alltag brauchen dass
die unterstützung bekommen eben genau
das auszufüllen also ich dieses
windhundprinzip was ihr sagen das sehen
wir nicht sehen wir auch keine gefahr da
können wir vielleicht grade auch noch
mal eingehen auf die kollegen von ihnen
vor ort die sich das anschauen das sind
auch pastoren und pastorinnen die vor
ort sind und auch dann einschätzungen
abgeben wo das geld besonders dringend
gebraucht wird
es stimmt also die das sind
sachverständige aber werden auch in
meinen teams begleitet von einem
seelsorger das ist wir machen das
gemeinsam mit der evangelischen kirche
weil die menschen schreckliche dinge
erlebt haben also mein kollege der das
hochwasser helfen koordiniert war heute
in hagen der erzählte mir im nachhinein
von einer familie die ist aus dem haus
geflüchtet und der oper ist noch mal im
keller und der ist nie wieder
hochgekommen der ist im grunde vor deren
augen ertrunken und solche geschichten
gibt es wirklich viele und dieses paket
tragen die menschen mit sich gerade also
es sind wirklich ganz dramatische dinge
und auch das muss aufgefangen werden
also das ist das was ich eben sagt es
geht auch und das ist im fokus natürlich
das ausgebende gelder aber es geht auch
darum zu helfen
zum einen die hilfen zu bekommen aber
auch hilfen im alltag im leben mit
diesem paket müssen viele menschen dort
leben und das muss aufgefangen werden
und das wird eine weile dauern weil die
meisten gerade der beschäftigt sind mit
anpacken mitmachen der kollege erzählte
ein anderes beispiel leute gestandener
mann der sagte ich
habe dich gern am liebsten einfach in
mein bett fallen wenn ich aber es ist
kein bett mehr da
im moment sind viele noch
heftig und tun und machen aber
irgendwann werden die in loch fallen und
dann ist es muss man da sein auch wenn
es vielleicht ein medial nicht mehr so
präsent ist aber wir werden dann vor ort
sein doch noch mal eine frage ob von
facebook hier an uns schaden belegen
wird sehr schwer wenn alle unterlagen
verschwunden sind oder nicht wie sieht
das aus
sie müssen nur belegen dass sie
entscheiden haben also wenn sie die
disco zerstörte wohnungen fotografieren
natürlich haben sie die rechnung nicht
mehr die wie kann niemand dieses im
zweifel weg aber einreichen gilt werden
sie jetzt ein neues bett sofa küche
kaufen die rechnung einreichen und den
schaden belegen dass sie vom hochwasser
betroffen sind also nicht es geht nicht
um die
das zerstörte so fotografieren dass im
zweifel ja schon abtransportiert worden
mit dem schutz und es ist gar nicht mehr
da das nicht sondern nur belegen dass
man geschädigt ist okay also das müsste
sich dann doch machen lassen wir hören
noch mal eine weitere kritische stimme
zur unübersichtlichkeit des verfahrens
diesmal von einer dame aus der nähe von
köln mein name ist khan ja siebert und
ich wohne in overath bei köln und wir
sind auch von dem hochwasser betroffen
was mir wirklich gefehlt hat ist auf den
der seite der aktion deutschland hilft
und auch der bündnispartner neben dem
spenden daten einen großen button hier
hilfe beantragen unter nach n-standard
dieser prozess wo ganz klar drin steht
wenn sie hier hilfe beantragen zahlen
wie rix prozent ihrer ermittelten
schadenssumme einer unserer mitarbeiter
wird rauskommen wird sich den schaden
angesehen wird es begutachten sie
kriegen die summe ausgezahlt
das ist ja kein hexenwerk heute und das
zu digitalisieren und selbst für die
menschen die keinen strom mehr haben ist
es auch möglich indem man einfach
wurfzettel machten mit den anträgen
ja vielleicht kann man das an der stelle
nochmal aufgreifen bevor sie antworten
also die frage nach dem standardisierten
verfahren wir gucken gerade mal hier auf
der seite des aktionsbündnisses
katastrophenhilfe und da ist es in der
tat so also man wird natürlich sehr
eindringlich darauf aufmerksam gemacht
wo man spenden kann und dass die
spendenbereitschaft groß ist das ist ja
auch gut so aber wenn man jetzt weiter
runter scrollt ist es schwierig da
irgendwo was zu entdecken wo man
tatsächlich sich melden kann als
betroffener anders ist es hingegen wenn
man bei ihnen schaut auf der seite das
ist also die diakonie
rheinland-westfalen-lippe wenn man da
nicht weit runter scrollt dann kommt man
hier zu den hochwasser hilfen ich gehe
da gerade mal drauf und dann sieht man
auch schon die anträge für möbel und
haushaltsgeräte von denen sie dafür auch
schon gesprochen haben da ist dann auch
relativ detailliert erklärt was man da
machen muss zum einen sich mal alles
durch zu lesen das ist klar aber auch
eben dann die weiteren schritte und
insofern würde ich sagen kann man da
schon ganz gut eigentlich nachvollziehen
was jetzt zu tun ist und da wäre jetzt
die frage halten sie das dann auch immer
dann auf dem laufen dann also auch jetzt
was die nächsten schritte dann also die
wiederaufbauhilfen angeht wird das dann
auch da zu finden sein
ja also die seite ist immer aktuell und
betrifft natürlich genau wie die gebiete
im rheinland und in rheinland pfalz und
uns wichtig dass man aus das haben sich
guckt also wie viele bei uns ist mit
zwei klicks auf diesem antrag
ehrlich gesagt haben wir diese die info
wo kann man spenden schon relativ weit
runter genommen weil das nicht mehr das
entscheidende gerade essen entscheidend
ist wie wird das geld ausgegeben und wie
kann ich bekommen und das ist schon
wichtig und das ist vielleicht müsste
man das auf allen seiten ändern
weil das natürlich das ist was jetzt
gerade am meisten
benötigt wird und das finde ich muss auf
der startseite klar sein und ich muss in
zwei klicks da sein trotzdem gibt es
natürlich auch leute die sagen ich habe
gar kein internet auch der werden mobile
teams helfen oder sagen ich kann es
ausdrucken wir werden diese hilfen
kriegen wir werden diese hilfen
beantragen und dabei unterstützen diese
hilfen zu bekommen also selbst wenn
jemand gerade technisch nicht
ausgestattet ist oder so aber wichtig
ist da gebe ich ihnen recht dass man das
jetzt schnell findet also man kann sich
da nicht was weit durch eine seite
klicken müssen und das muss auch
verständlich sein ja das mit sicherheit
auch im sinne der betroffenen und
unserer user hier auch die dame hatte
das noch angefügt es sei kein gut
sichtbarer button unterschiedliche
summen das war auch noch ein punkt
unterschiedliche summen würden
ausgezahlt von den verschiedenen
bündnispartnern und das sei nicht
besonders vertrauenserweckend wie kommt
das zustande dass also verschiedene
organisationen der unterschiedlichen
ansätzen oder haben sie da andere
erfahrungen
ich kann nicht für alle sprechen da wie
es ist also diese 5000 euro jetzt bei
dem holz beihilfen beispielsweise ist
die höchstgrenze die wir auch mit der
diakonie katastrophenhilfe haben wo eben
eine bedürftigkeitsprüfung juni
stattfinden muss also etwas das was man
noch einreichen kann im unbürokratisch
damit es schnell geht es wenn ich jetzt
dafür auch noch sonstige sachen offen
legen müsste würde das im wege stehen
dessen dass ich das jetzt möglich
schnell machen will deshalb war das für
uns die höchstgrenzen beispielsweise
ok frau haben dann vielleicht auch als
schluss frage an sie also was glauben
sie jetzt was ist in den nächsten tagen
und wochen für sie auch entscheidend
worauf legen sie jetzt noch mal einen
besonderen fokus
also die
haushalts war helfen die sind diese
woche angelaufen aber bei uns da sind
jetzt schon mehrere hundert anträge das
muss jetzt ganz zügig umgesetzt werden
damit sehr schnell schnell ankommt ich
glaube dass die beratung jetzt auch
gerade wichtig ist weil natürlich wenn
ihr heute die staatlichen hilfen zu
beantragen sind da wären da fragen
auftauchen die es zu beantworten gilt
also was muss ich in welcher reihenfolge
machen also das beratungsangebot wird
glaube ich jetzt verstärkt werden in
houston nächste woche
was jetzt kommt wird es um diese
heizungs geräte gehen und dann waren wir
eben oder arbeiten mit hochdruck an
diesem mobilen teams damit die möglich
schnell vor ort sind in besonders
betroffenen regionen um da ganz
pragmatisch wirklich daneben zu sitzen
und gemeinsam das auszufüllen damit die
hilfen noch ankommen ja also hilfe beim
ausfüllen der formulare das scheint ganz
wichtig zu sein aber eben auch noch mal
der hinweis es wird noch ein bisschen
dauern im einen oder anderen fall
zumindest was die größeren hilfen angeht
also ein bisschen geduld ist wohl doch
noch erforderlich
genau erforderlich weil es eben einfach
so geregelt ist das ist nichts was wohl
sagen wir halten das mal zurück sondern
es ist geregelt dass er staatliche
hilfen versicherung das ist einfach so
und ich kann die ungeduld wirklich gut
verstehen und aber wir versuchen das
umzusetzen was gerade am nötigsten und
am meisten an gefordert wird und am
ersten tag fragt auch keiner ein haus
wieder aufbauen sondern ging es um eben
diese sofort ist und wir gehen schritt
für schritt und wir gehen dadurch und
zügig und ohne eine aufgeblähte
verwaltung
aber man kann nur den zweiten schritt
nach dem ersten gehen und den werden wir
gehen und das geld wird dort vor ort
ausgegeben werden ja also ich denke wir
haben deutlich machen können das ist
keine ganz einfache aufgabe ist und dass
sie ihr bestes tun vielen dank gahan war
das leiterin für öffentlichkeitsarbeit
des diakonischen werks
rheinland-westfalen-lippe danke schön
für das gespräch und einen schönen abend
und viel erfolg weiterhin natürlich auch
für ihre arbeit auf das ist möglich
schnell gehen möge vielen dank auch noch
mal an unsere user euch allen einen
schönen abend und auch ein schönes
wochenende bis demnächst